[Music]
on this thursday night the devastating
drought decimating crops in canada
the extreme heat bone-dry conditions
some farmers say there's nothing left
it'll be a hit across the west
across most cattle operations from
northwestern ontario all the way into bc
plus hundreds of wildfires rage
including in bc
if the fire comes here it's there's not
really much hope fierce winds fan the
already explosive situation in wine
country
denying there's any infighting what the
head of the green party says about the
latest legal challenge to her leadership
a father speaks out about a racist
attack on his family
they said i found you i'm gonna kill you
will a federal summit on islamophobia
bring
real change and another olympic scandal
on the eve
of the opening ceremony
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the hot dry conditions in
large swaths of this country
and how the drought is affecting the
food supply farmers are being hit hard
this map shows drought conditions as of
june 30th
yellow which snakes across much of the
country needs abnormally dry
red is extreme and dark brown is
exceptional drought conditions
the driest regions are in southern
manitoba and saskatchewan
several municipalities have declared
states of agricultural disaster
crops are failing pastures are bone dry
and there isn't enough feed for cattle
some farmers are selling
off entire herds and they know prolonged
heat waves are becoming more common
even if you're not a farmer it will
affect you heather urex west has our top
story tonight
yeah normally i mean we'd be a little
bit higher so we're a little bit shorter
ian chitwood considers himself lucky his
canola crop south of calgary
is hanging on despite a summer of
soaring temperatures
and little rain overall we're right in
this area we're okay but
we need some rain soon an hour south in
vulcan county
the situation is far more severe the
county has declared a municipal
agricultural
disaster most of the crop in the region
has been lost
this is widespread i haven't seen many
nice crops in southern alberta which is
uh
so which is surprising typically there's
going to be pockets that have received
you know some good rain um but
there's there's really nothing this year
but vulcan county is not alone
drought conditions are breeding
desperation for farmers across the
country
from bc's interior to eastern ontario
in manitoba's interlake region normally
green grazing pastures used for cattle
are dry brown and dead forcing many beef
producers in the area to sell the
animals they are no longer
able to feed it's a heart-wrenching
um circumstance these these are
operations that have been uh
you know in in the family for three and
four generations and they're being
forced to make
decisions that really undermine the the
viability of their farm
food producers are used to battling the
elements in canada
and canadian farmers have seen at least
two other droughts like this
in the last 40 years but climate change
projections are that drought could
become more
severe more intense and more frequent
that's a problem not only for farmers
but
consumers too food prices are already
expected to rise this year by an average
of five percent
with some items like meat expected to
surge even more
to produce food in general in the fall
will likely be more expensive for
everyone
a painful extension of a drought few
canadian farmers have seen before
but will more than likely have to face
again heather eurex west global news
near eritrea alberta
now to bc where hot dry and windy
conditions persist
posing an imminent threat to fire crews
and to residents
this video was captured last night it's
the incamy
creek fire burning near soyuz in bc's
wine country
a first nation in the area says strong
winds sent the fire racing towards a
number of homes last night
fire crews got to the scene just in time
and managed
to hold it back
not far from where that fire is burning
homeowners are anxiously watching the
weather
and doing what they can to protect their
property
we put sprinklers on the roof just to
try and
keep it soaked as much as possible
everybody's freaking out we're all
you know just wondering what's gonna
happen next you know the
the winds go in the right direction it's
in our favor right now but
that may not last long and and we're
we're
all desperate to to keep our houses keep
our families
safe
as of tonight more than 260 wildfires
are actively burning across bc
89 of them are out of control more than
forty three hundred properties are under
evacuation order
officials are warning of challenging
days ahead
global's paul johnson is in suyus in
southern bc
tracking the inca meat fire tonight paul
what can you tell us donna
assoyus oliver and vicinity appear to be
holding their own
thursday the fire is still very active
and dangerous and likely grew overnight
where they came close to having some
very catastrophic damage
late wednesday night things were looking
much worse
strong winds blew the fire up and for a
time it was threatening homes on spirit
ridge
none of those homes were damaged but
some reports had the fire reaching
people's driveways
those homes are on property owned by the
assoyus indian band
which is where most of the fire has been
burning soyuz band chief
clarence louis said the situation is a
reminder of how careful people need to
be
with these extreme conditions stay out
of the back country
we just went through record heat waves
in this province record heat waves
and it's so dry out there it's it it's
normally dry
this is also the heart of bc's wine
country
and for many wineries and tasting rooms
here
hopes of a sweet recovery from the
pandemic
have been dashed unfortunately we are
losing
some of our tourism but i think just
keeping
everybody safe and keeping this the
community safe
is the best steps that we could take
and the incoming fire is only one of the
many serious fires burning in british
columbia right now
[Music]
further north in sycamous the mayor had
to scold
reckless boaters who've been threatening
the operation of
water tanker planes loading up on shoe
swap lake
if you come to our community and you're
here
or you're coming to it you've got to
respect the situation that's happening
here right now
just think about it think about it be
smart
be respectful so for british columbians
many of them who might be feeling like
they're at their wits end
after several weeks of extreme wildfires
some of the promised help
is close to being here we're a bit hazy
in the exact
time frame but we're expecting several
dozen firefighters
from mexico to be arriving here in soyuz
and to be based out of here
it's also worth noting that across the
province where normally
you would see active logging taking
place right now where there is wildfire
danger
a lot of those people and machines that
would be used in logging
have been seconded to help fight these
wildfires
donna so much help needed paul johnson
in a soyuz bc thanks
wildfires respect no boundaries of
course and in the u.s dozens of fires
are burning in the west
sending smoke all the way across the
country prompting air quality advisories
as far away
as new york city oregon's bootleg fire
is the largest in the country
so big it can be seen from space and so
out of control
it's generating its own weather system
it's one of more than 80 fires burning
out of control across 13 states
jennifer johnson on what's fueling them
and the impact they're having
even on people who live thousands of
kilometers away
thousands of firefighters are still
unable to control oregon's massive
bootleg
fire two weeks after it was sparked by
lightning
the fire has destroyed more than 162
thousand hectares of forest and land
crews from as far away as arkansas and
alaska have been called in to help
it's going to take a lot more boots on
the ground to get this under control the
fire is so huge
its smoky haze has spread across the
entire country
forcing air quality warnings for
millions
i was having a little trouble with
trying to catch my breath and breathing
health officials in new york new jersey
and pennsylvania are telling people with
heart and lung conditions
to stay inside we're worrying more about
fine particles these fine particle
particles can really irritate the inner
linings of the lungs
and cause respiratory problems poor air
quality from so many fires
another result of climate change which
has created tinderbox conditions
throughout the west
the impacts of climate change may be
seen in many different ways
including droughts floods increased
storms
wildfires both in terms of extent and
intensity
the bootleg fire is one of dozens
turning the west into a giant fireball
california's tamarack fire is spreading
so fast it has now crossed state lines
into nevada
we got 10 minutes to get in and get we
can get and then it's time to leave
california's largest utility pacific gas
and electric
is now pledging to bury tens of
thousands of kilometers of power lines
after its equipment possibly touched off
the dixie fire
near the town of paradise which was
destroyed by the camp fire three years
ago
we are committing today to undertake one
of the largest
infrastructure projects in the history
of our state starting in our highest
fire threat districts
in the meantime these fires remain
explosive and uncontained
with the worst the wildfire season along
the west coast
still expected to come in august and
september
jennifer johnson global news washington
the leader of canada's green party
denies there is any infighting going on
within the party but there
are still members agitating to remove
anime paul as leader
and they're not giving up their legal
fight it's unfolding in the weeks before
an expected federal election call
abigail beeman looks at what's going on
within the greens
[Applause]
green party leader annemie paul opens
her new campaign office in toronto
as threats to her leadership have been
reopened
i am not feuding with anyone i am not
seeking to there is no there is no
infighting going on this is really a
one-sided
attack but the details are not clear and
paul isn't speaking to them
here's what we know the green party of
canada and the green party of canada
fund a separate legal entity filed a
challenge at the ontario superior court
calling for an arbitrator's recent
decision to be overturned
that decision ordered the party to
suspend paul's membership review
until new members of its federal council
take office next month
and postpone a non-confidence vote
lawyers argue the arbitrator made a
number of
errors of law it is complicated paul
signed an employment contract with the
green party fund
not the party itself so party lawyers
argue the arbitrator couldn't instruct
it what to do
from a legal standpoint that makes
really good viable
legal sense employment lawyer muniza
sheikh says what happens is significant
for
anyone who holds public office with an
employment contract
if the agreement is pitched out the
window
then ultimately it could be a
precedent-setting decision
paul isn't saying how or even whether
she plans to respond
these are the actions of a small group
of outgoing
counselors this was not an action
sanctioned by our federal council
neither the federal council nor the
green party fund would comment
with the specter of a federal election
and the greens pushing to become more
relevant
nationally a legal fight and anyone's
attention away from a campaign
can't help paul maintains she won't be
distracted
abigail beeman global news ottawa
an apology to australians coming up why
that country's prime minister
is saying sorry
canada's covet 19 vaccination campaign
passed a significant threshold today on
two fronts
more than 80 percent of people over the
age of 12 have now had at least one dose
and over 60 percent of canadians are now
fully vaccinated with
two doses but vaccine uptake has
slowed considerably yesterday about 324
000 canadians received
their second dose that's compared to a
peak of over over 484
000 doses given in one day less than a
month ago
and there is positive news those
vaccines are protecting against
variants a study published in the new
england journal of medicine
found two doses of pfizer or astrazeneca
is highly effective against the highly
transmissible variant
spreading around the world the study
found two doses of the pfizer vaccine
were 88 percent effective at preventing
symptomatic disease from the delta
variant
two shots of astrazeneca were 67
effective only modest differences in
vaccine effectiveness were noted with
the delta variant
compared with the previous alpha variant
australia's prime minister is
apologizing for his government's slow
vaccine rollout scott morrison is under
mounting pressure to take responsibility
for the increasing lockdowns
and the spread of the variant there only
about 15 percent of eligible australians
have had
both doses i'm certainly sorry that we
haven't been able to achieve the marks
that we had hoped for at the beginning
of this year of course i am
south wales australia's most populous
state reported 124
new coven 19 cases today the highest
number in 16 months
13 million people about half the
country's population are under lockdown
to try to keep
the highly contagious delta variant from
spreading further
china has rejected a proposal from the
world health organization to further
investigate the origins of covet 19.
first of all
a chinese health official says he was
taken aback by the proposal to have
experts return to places in wuhan
that they had visited earlier this year
and also investigate the hypothesis that
the virus
may have leaked from a lab that idea was
dismissed as
counter to common sense and science
kovid 19 was first detected in wuhan
in 2019. the who's initial origin study
determined the virus
likely jumped from animals to humans but
a growing number of western nations have
questioned the thoroughness of that
report
the who is now calling on china to
provide better access to data it
compiled
in the early days of the pandemic
still ahead tackling islamophobia in
canada
why action is needed now more than ever
you're watching global national
[Music]
prime minister justin trudeau is vowing
to take action to stamp out hate and
islamophobia
he made that promise at a national
summit on islamophobia today
there is concern though his words won't
translate into action
and as mike trolley reports families are
dealing with acts of hate right now
and cases are on the rise imam kamal
kerji felt helpless when his wife called
him last week
she was with their daughter in a
pharmacy parking lot when she says a man
in a truck yelling racist slurs tried to
run them down
and then he chased them and and they
ignored his remarks they walked away and
he chased them actually where they
started running and hidden bushes and
he followed my wife and when he found
her she he said
i found you i'm going to kill you
fortunately bystanders stepped in and
the man was eventually arrested and
charged
kergey says his thoughts went
immediately to four members of the afzal
family
who were run over and killed in an
alleged hate crime six weeks ago
in nearby london ontario it is very
similar to what happened
in london except that the perpetrator
this time did not succeed
it's on the heels of those incidents in
a series of hate-related crimes
targeting muslims across the country
that the federal government convened a
virtual summit
on islamophobia to young muslims who
take to the streets to advocate and
protest
who call on their elected officials to
do more
we see you and we hear you professor
andre iman of the
institute of islamic studies at the
university of toronto is hopeful for
change
but he sees islamophobia as a problem
that's pervasive in society
and that includes government the school
has released a study that found
government audits routinely target
and are biased against muslim charities
for example
my concern is that we're going to work
and we're going to we're going to treat
the government at this summit like as if
it were some
neutral umpire trying to make sure
people get along
in society but i don't think it's a
neutral umpire it's
actually a participant and an enabler of
these things
change and accountability speaking truth
to power
he says can be uncomfortable but without
it he doesn't see lasting progress
happening
mike relay global news toronto
next the olympic opening ceremony will
go ahead without its director
why he just got fired
i guess you could call this a crime of
passion a security camera caught this
couple crashing through the window of a
montreal barber shop
you can see them stumble into the
entrance area just before
seven in the morning they well you know
lock lips and then lean into the door
and the glass shatters
the shop owner shared the video online
he says he wants to find the couple and
buy them a night at a hotel he's put a
souvenir of the incident up on the wall
of his shop
well hosting the olympics is supposed to
be an economic windfall
and a point of pride for the host
country the whole world watches
excited fans crowd into the stands the
tokyo games already delayed by year
because of covid are turning into a
billion dollar bust for japan
and now the director of the opening
ceremony has been fired
crystal commansing explains as the
olympic torch embarked on the final leg
of its journey the tokyo
president fired the director of the
opening ceremony
a move possibly to uphold the values the
torch symbolizes
peace friendship tolerance and hope
quintero has been found to have used
lines in his own performances in the
past that made fun of painful historical
facts said the game's president
adding in response the organizing
committee has decided to dismiss
mr kobayachi officials claim that they
just became
aware of the material making light of
the holocaust although
it was from the 1990s kobayashi is the
third
disgraced high-ranking official linked
to the opening and closing ceremonies
now on the outside k igo oyamada a
composer
resigned acknowledging he bullied
disabled classmates
hiroshi sasaki the game's creative lead
made disparaging remarks about a
plus-sized japanese performer
and yashiro mori the president of the
tokyo olympic organizing committee
left his post in february after making
sexist comments
it's something that we continue to see
with high-ranking officials around the
world
laura meisner is an associate professor
and executive member of the
international center for olympic studies
she isn't shocked by the controversies
or even the director losing his job
she does question the timing of his
firing and much of the attention has
been focused on coped so i think
anything to deflect the attention away
from that
is likely what we're seeing happening
two more athletes have
tested positive as of thursday afternoon
there were at least
87 olympic related cases among athletes
and accredited individuals and nearly 2
000 new cases were reported in tokyo
alone
all eyes are turning to the opening
ceremonies and many are wondering what
the mood will be like it's supposed to
be a celebration
but given the firing and the pandemic
the kickoff
could be a somber and possibly worrisome
event
officials are still planning to have 950
special guests
and athletes attend in person crystal
gomencing global news
london that's global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is a smoky
sunset in the okanagan valley in bc we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching
paranasser will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and i'll see you again next
week
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you